and this is work you did you said 1979
1979 work for Hire One Shot story done
as kind of a a joke and was that an
opportunity that was an interesting
thing where you you know someone else
might have turned it down or no this was
something that you were doing on well no
this was just I was at I was at another
party at at Rick oberg's the artist
house and the artist was there I mean
the um the editor Roy Thomas was there
and we were Rick and I was were just
kind of come up with all these crazy
ideas for potential what if stories and
I I don't even know who came up with the
idea I think it was me I said what if
Thor was the hammer was found by Jane
Foster and we were you know we were had
a couple drinks who were a little bit
loose you know coming with crazier and
crazy ideas and we went up to Roy hey
what about what do you think of this
because he turned down a bunch of the
ones we came up with and he said yeah
that sounds like a good idea run with it
so the next day I was busy bus working
out the story and um see in those in in
Marvel the the way you write wrote a
story was different every company had
their own method when I worked at uh
when I'm working now doing these shutter
and vampirus Carmela stories you write a
script like a movie script pretty much
you describe everything and give
everybody dialogue when I worked at gold
key Comics it was more you got sat down
with a sheet because they were used to
working with cartoonists so you got a
sheet of paper and you're ruled off with
a ruler where the panels would go and
then you would write in each rectangle
or square what was going on and if you
and if you went off beyond the line you
know You' got too much on the page with
Marvel you would talk to the artist you
would write up a a synopsis The synopsis
might be one paragraph or two paragraphs
and you give it to the artist and the
artist would draw it up any way he wants
and then you would get get the art back
and you would get these penciled you
know like a fight that would gone for
four pages where in your synopsis all
you're write was they fight and artist
kind of came up with all that and then
you write all the balloons and the
captions and the sound effects over the
artwork and then the inkor and the
letter would come and they would edit
letter the artwork and um and ink in the
the artwork and then then color it so it
was like working backwards in a way
so each company had their own way of
doing it with the dialogue that you
submit is the artwork then matched
exactly Page by Page frame by frame well
that's a really good question um and a
lot of writers don't understand it or
artist when you write a regular script
in script form you don't know where the
you don't see any artwork it's not done
yet when you do it um the gold key
fashion they
would you would get the script and
before the artwork was even done they
would drawing balloons and the artists
would have to work around where the
balloons were to fit the artwork in
Marvel style which is the easiest way I
thought when you wrote a synopsis and
then they came they sent you the
penciled artwork and there's no artwork
there's no uh inks yet and there's no
dialogue and there's no text at
all then you write the text to fit the
artwork and the art first of all the
artist has to leave you room to put text
someplace then you've got to put the
artwor the the the text so the reader
reads it in the correct sequence you
can't have a question answer asked here
and the answer asked someplace over here
with something in between where there
somebody's talking it's got to follow
you got to follow it like you're a
conversation
and then the are you you as a writer
have to place taking all that into
account you have to place the balloons
and things so it doesn't cover up an
important piece of artwork you don't
want to have a character who's talking
have the balloon over his face it's got
to be from some dead space or whatever
that's a trick it took me a while to
learn that and a lot of artists and
writers don't know how to do that it's a
it's just a a knack you pick up after a
while so so you're seeing the artwork
already laid out yeah when you when you
when you work for
Marvel except they they have done an
occasion script all you know writing a
full script generally at Marvel you
write a synopsis and it might
be Captain America fights Dr Doom for
possession of
a magic thing or some sort you know
during the fight Captain America loses
as she
you know very J general things like that
then what you get usually in the old
days it was in the mail it came in the
mail in a big envelope like this was the
artwork penciled on big sheets of some
kind of board and then you would write
your script you might see a panel that
looks really great by itself why ruin it
with putting dialogue in let's just
leave it as is
and you don't know until you see the
artwork then they send it back it gets
lettered and then an inchor comes in and
he inks it and um it's a different it's
it's a way of being able to mass produce
these things like an assembly line while
one person is lettering it the other
person is writing it somebody else is
drawing it and you can do you can work a
lot faster that way the only time in
recent years me recent decades actually
that it was actually a thrill saying my
name on anything
for something i' done there's a new
movie just came out called Thor love and
thunder it's based on the idea that Dr
Don Blake who trally traditionally
became Thor in the comic books didn't
that that it was actually his nurse and
girlfriend Jane Foster who became
Thor that was inspired by a comic book
story that I wrote and that artist Rick
hobber Drew in
1979 uh for a comic a Marvel comic
called what if and we coming up with all
these silly ideas what if Spider-Man had
two heads or something you know and one
of them was what if Jane Foster found
the hammer of Thor and became Thor there
was a one shot never intended to go
beyond that one issue of what if and and
thought of as kind of a half
joke well in recent years somebody
picked up on that idea in the comic
books in the Marvel Comics and it's
become part of the
mainstream
continuity to the extent where they
decided to make a movie out of this
hundreds of millions of dollar movie
well Marvel was really good Marvel
remembered Rick Colberg and my and
myself for this they um invited us to
the screen the world premiere grman
Chinese Theater we got to walk the red
carpet and all
that and uh they paid us I won't say how
much but they paid us very handsomely
and they didn't have to do this remember
this is a work for hire the storyline
was almost nothing of what what I came
up with it except the ending was a
little bit the same but it was mostly
they just took the idea of Jane Foster
becoming Thor that was
it
and we're sitting there at grman shines
theater looking at the iMac screen and
our name comes up at the end in the end
credits that was a big deal deal that
was a really big deal um so I'm grateful
I'm really thankful for Marv to Marvel
for doing that people who worked for the
companies like Marvel and
DC always complaining they were ripped
off never remembered never give any
money never give any credit and I got to
say Marvel came through for us we didn't
even ask him I asked him at one point is
it possible this will ever Happ we'll
get some kind of recognition out of this
and all they said was we'll see we'll
get back to you and they got back to us
in a very nice way so I'm really
grateful and thankful and seeing your
name on the iMac screen at groundman
Chinese Theater with all the footprints
outside in the front lobby was a big
deal